the scenes may look familiar but for
Hong Kong
it feels that so much more is now at
stake on Friday
Beijing unveiled plans to impose
controversial national security laws on
the city today protesters gave their
reply
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh hey guys are all the hood on we are
Thunder isn't welcome here
so the : Tyler Tyler hanta all it's your
teeth the colors I corn NSYNC anima
Tyler yeah Tom gun clatters oh go on
fallow she's up in your the fire colors
I appreciate the Frank Iero the police
were ready for them the widely joint
security law would ban subversion
secession foreign interference and any
act that threatens national security but
many worried they'll be used to limit
Hong Kong's traditional freedoms of
speech of the press and of course of
protest
so they defied social distancing rules
to protest while they still can and the
hostilities put on hold at the end of
last year resumed in 2019 police fired
16 thousand rounds of tear gas in total
this was the first salvo of the year
that promises to be just as long and
intense 1200 miles north Beijing is
under tight control as the capital
continues to hold the country's annual
rubber stamp Parliament this ultimately
is what the Communist leadership wants a
Hong Kong - suruli condo soldier
co-teaching finisher lee sunji body
computer Shenzhen
why was Sri session to the free Falcon
solution such a total Shoob got a course
on shame
sergeant umbrella it is Shankar
partially in follow to geocode am Jill
Coachella mm these are protesters not
violent terrorists and this is not a
Hong Kong police force diligent
the odds are stacked against Hong Kong
but they will not get down without a
fight
top Cheshire Sky News Beijing